[Music]
do you guys have your settings
on your apple products in a way where
taika can't rack up purchases on apps
yes yes he doesn't know anything he
doesn't know anything
yes i thought you had to go like click
click put your face in or password
well dude i've heard some horror stories
bro i have a horror story for you
a 16 000 horse oh my god
how do you buy that much [ __ ] kids just
click on [ __ ]
kids can just keep clicking too huh so
this six-year-old
named george from connecticut he
racked up sixteen thousand
two hundred and ninety three dollars and
ten cents how does the game let that
happen
without could be multiple things it was
multiple purchases that racked up to
that amount i understood well
anyway this kid he was playing this
sonic game
and he i sonic [ __ ] i can already see
the [ __ ]
sony yeah it's sony sold already but
just write it go
sony go write it don't need the
headphones
there's new sonics by the way okay thank
you
so this is what the game looks like and
so this kid was buying these red rings
that cost
real money so he'd start off with the
dollar 99
he worked his way up to 4.99 eventually
he was
getting up racking up 99.99
well you try a little bit then you get
into more of an expensive taste the mom
said
she was like it was like my six-year-old
was doing lines of cocaine like
damn that's what it looks like it looks
if that was white
instead of red these games are
programmed to give you doses like
cocaine yeah
she's like doing bigger and bigger hits
dude my grandma's obsessed with the
[ __ ] mobile game like this oh yeah
mm-hmm did they buy the upsells yeah my
grandma does fall for it
your mom does my grandma your grandma
she buys the wizard of oz game all
[ __ ] day long
okay so i will admit that i did it in
design home
but not right out purchased it but you
can sign up for things
and then you get a certain level of
coins wait why are you embarrassing
sometimes
how much you have to buy something at
that company you can't return it but in
my head i justified it because i'm like
oh not only am i getting more
more coins for the game but i also get
uh this skirt that is kind of cool i
guess
i've also spent money on gaming i didn't
want to do it
you only did it once girl i don't even
want to tell you no i've done it
oh [ __ ] too animal crosstalk just like
no it's just like if i could spend money
in animal crossing [ __ ] i would
probably actually i have the the mobile
app
animal crossing game what was it called
again a pocket camera
yeah i did sign up to like it was like
three dollars
but still i paid money like that's what
i mean like i've actually
paid physical money for these [ __ ]
games it wasn't did you spend a lot of
time
no no it was like two dollars here why
are you so cute
for that i'm not guilty i'm just sharing
with nikki
like i have also 2013 i got into [ __ ]
madden ultimate team like i was because
i
i love to play madden and uh they have
this thing called ultimate team you can
spend real money on and i [ __ ] spent
real money for sure
how much do you remember i probably
spent like 250 dollars on this one
because it's because you know your
potential like you know how good you are
without spending money yes but if you
could just get these
extra hits yeah yeah you could be so
good how i justified it was true though
after you paid
oh okay i was like it's worth it i was
like okay a video game is 60
i don't want to buy any other games but
man so i'm just buying
madden over and over again justified
justified
you know what's so stupid remember that
word search game that we both played
and then like it would give you it would
give you oh like the letters are
scrambled yeah the scrambled ones and
then
and then it gives you like coins that
you can like um yeah and you never used
it and i never used those and that
that literally cost me no real money
yeah and maybe that's why i never used
it because
i'm like i don't want it there's no
sacrifice to use my room i want to waste
real money
i don't know like i don't know what the
logic is but like i'm saying i did not
have to pay real money to get these
these coins you paid money still no no i
didn't
i did it but i'm saying but i'm saying
like i am actually paying real money
for other games in that game she's like
i don't want to ever pay money so i'm
going to save these
all these free coins i don't even know
if you can pay probably they need to
make money somehow
but for some reason and then also i kind
of feel proud though because i'm like
[ __ ] yeah look how advanced i got in
this game and i never use those things
i was like how the [ __ ] does stiff does
it she's a [ __ ] genius like i was
always that negative i'd have to wait
till the next
game was it so it's like they scramble
letters and then you make as many words
like you start something
they'll say like make 20 words letters
but that doesn't even sound fun like
madden was fun
it's really fun but i like to learn okay
we don't like to lose brain cells
it's not losing brain cells if you know
what the offense and defense is
if you know how to play nickel dime oh
it's stratus struck a chord
i see yeah it's got your baby's strategy
right
i needed a [ __ ] center okay my
quarterback's getting sacked every
[ __ ] game
all right so back to this story here
with little georgie so it all started in
the month of july
okay how old is this guy six so in july
so on july 9th jessica was working in
the next room which is her
mother um real estate broker by the way
and so
there were 25 charges totaling over 2
500 so then when jessica discovered
the hefty apple and paypal amounts
because it emails you
every time you get charged yeah but but
the thing is they were bundling it
and for some reason for her it was
really difficult to find out where this
was coming from so she said
that she noticed that apple and paypal
were withdrawing from her chase account
and she would see like 562 dollars here
601 dollars there
she assumed it was a mistake or a fraud
so then she called
chase because these items were
un-itemized
um and charges so she didn't know what
they were and so
she ended up calling chase and then
chase said oh yeah it's most likely
fraud
so she filed a fraud claim in july when
her bill reached
that total amount 16 293 and 10 cents
but it wasn't until october that chase
told her that those charges were indeed
hers and she needs to figure it out with
apple
they waited until october to tell her
this so then finally when she reached
out to apple
she was walked through a buried running
list of all the charges that you
wouldn't know how to find it without
something
someone directing you and then so when
she saw the sonic icon she knew that
that was
george so then apple said tough they
told me that because i didn't call
within 60 days of the charges and
they can't do anything and then she says
like the reason i didn't call within 60
days because chase told me it was likely
fraud and that apple on paypal.com are
top fraud charges
but apple didn't care they were just
like well
you should there's a setting you should
have known to set it that
like to that setting so that your
six-year-old wouldn't be
charging up so many so many things so
then
she said that um obviously if she knew
that there was a [ __ ] setting she
would have said it that way and her
child would have never racked up all
these charges um
and so no you know what i wanted to have
sixteen thousand dollars with sonic
coins
i know it's like what we got apple
wouldn't help her and so now she's just
stuck with this
crazy debt and like i said she's a real
estate broker so she makes her income
based off of commission and she says
that she didn't get a paycheck from
march to september
and that her income has decreased by 80
percent this year oh my god
yeah so now she's like she's like i i
don't even know if i could pay my
mortgage and that bubbles like oh well
and then um so how can one game allow
you to spend 16 grand like all at once
that should be like you know they have
regulations in
casinos for gambling addicts and stuff
like how does that
it wasn't at once it was over time but
like oh like
been a short amount of time it was like
in the month of july yeah
seems like you should have to have
special permission to spend 16 g's in
the game over like having to [ __ ]
do anything else but it's really cute
because george was like
um he was like well i'll pay you back
mom
you better you low [ __ ] then she's like
she's like how well i pay him four
dollars to clean start a youtube channel
and he's gonna open up toys
it's cute because oh it's it's cute
cause
then he's exploiting she's exploiting
him for money he's paying off a debt
yeah it's not exploitation at that point
that's right
at that point everyone's gonna
understand they're like this fool needs
to work it off
can i ask is his character [ __ ] sick
in this game i don't know
i i picture being like he already has
all the coins but he just likes hitting
the button like and so he's even know
becoming even more and more wealthy in
this game how old is he six
because i'm like at six years old i'm
pretty sure i knew
a hundred dollars no she she even said
here that it'd be a big a huge qua
[ __ ] what a cognitive leap for him to
understand that
this is i mean are you in first grade
kindergartener
but it's also not physical money you
know what i mean so he's just like yeah
and he'll clear your spouse you'll hear
like you think yeah chimes
and like they don't like pop up a window
that's like just so you know it's real
real money
you should ask an adult they also make
it very satisfying yeah when i was
buying on madden ultimate team
but when it comes up and you open it and
you're like congratulations you opened
up a pot of gold yeah dude i could buy
all the art i wanted to design home and
it made my rooms come together
wow so this is her quote she said my son
doesn't understand that the money was
real how could he he's playing a cartoon
game
in a world that he know he knows is not
real why would the money be real to him
that would
require a big cognition makes so much
sense oh because if it was a hundred
dollars
then he's like that's money money right
and apple's like you didn't teach your
kid the value of money really [ __ ]
she also said i may have to force this
kid to pay me back in 15 years when he
gets his first job
oh my god so she's just stuck with this
bill it's over
apple's just like she should just start
a gofundme so this is jessica and george
dude every time she sees socks now she's
like god damn it
just like geo paying out my [ __ ] oh
that's rough man
now that kid can't say [ __ ] to mom for
the rest of his life
turn it back around george looks like he
just spent 16 years
he's like oh god tired
on a kid ipad it's his own independent
uh ipad he sounds so [ __ ] privileged
it's his own it's not connected to
anything we don't have any personal
information and it's on kid stuff so
anytime he wants
his face opens it how cute oh i believe
anytime he wants to upgrade or purchase
or whatever it'll give him a math
problem
or like and then like yeah like a
multiplication problem he could start
solving it he does want to know right
all the time
he likes playing the slot machine game
and then he'll like there's two of them
so it's like three squares
and he was like papa oh cause he'll
click the ones that are locked and you
can't go in
so he keeps looking at me like he wants
me to unlock it i'm like papa doesn't
know
oh wow so then in order to unlock it you
need real money
yeah so he just plays the free version i
like that you're naked he's playing a
slot machine because it was my mom's
ipad you're innately getting him
addicted to sloths but wait
you gotta give the whole i'm prepping
for vegas yeah you should
yeah that's gonna be your news it's a
hard time all right we've fallen on hard
times
we gotta we need money you're gonna send
them out to the casinos right
no it's grandma's fault because grandma
makes slots look so fun so now he wants
to play it really
yeah with the sound of money and
everything i think everyone enjoyed
remember when we were kids in real
quarters would fall out and you
and people go have buckets i thought
that was so cool like there's so much
coins in there dude chucky cheese coins
was sick too i was like god damn there's
a lot of coins coming out of there oh
that was priming goof
to go to a casino later true oh my god
it all makes them
conditioned and groomed to gamble
this guy knows it better than anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you